in the past i've looked for the worst
game on steam
ow my chin the first time i made a video
like this i played a game called
skyscraper simulator
and it was terrible because there was
legitimately nothing to do
oh there oh there they go oh look at him
go so then i followed up with a game
called jurassic island the dinosaur zoo
what is this what is i'm really trying
to understand what this is guys i'm
really trying to understand
that had a three percent rating and you
know i didn't think that it could be
beaten
but i have found a game that is actually
worse than either of those games
this game is not only bad
there is absolutely no potential for it
to be good
well actually let me back up a step in
my quest to
find the worst game currently i found a
game called
space launch engineer which has a
whopping zero percent
on steam and i loaded it up not only was
the game
hard to understand you have not told me
how to do that
do i control this but it also was just
plain
broken the state of the rocket what
happened it's going up
what it's going up it's going up what do
you mean the state of the rock what's
happening with the rocket why is it
going up
so while this game has a zero percent
and that is officially lower
than my previous criteria and and though
i had a poor time with the game
i do not qualify as that being a worst
game because that game was fundamentally
broken
even though and here you can see i play
around with space launch engineer and
it's
bad i can't click on
any of this night vision doesn't even
work
it's like you can't even see any better
why is description labeled desk
why is sub task over there one two three
one two three one two i don't know
this is in russian now it is not really
what i would call the worst maybe i'm
biased you know i like space
there is nothing i like more than space
but you know in my gut i didn't feel
like it was the worst
and then i played a game called
university tycoon 2019
also with a whopping zero percent but
this one
this one is evil this game
is a nightmare wrapped up in a game
might be a scam probably is because it
costs
twenty dollars to play resort
tycoon university tycoon 2019
resort tycoon i'm not sure exactly where
the confusion comes in there but this
game
should not be on steam the reviews
are as you'd expect you know this game
is just nothing right now
not even close to early access developer
have to put a lot of hours to finish
i remember recommend you guys wait until
anything changed before you buy it
for me the game idea is eight out of ten
overall is just two out of ten
this game is a really good idea however
in its current state the game is
unplayable very rudimentary it is not
close to early access at all the game
has no function don't download it
until it improves the game is useless
you can build walls and put in chairs
and that's it the money never changes
the students and teachers
are all john doe and the point of the
game is severely lacking
game idea is great currently unplayable
i knew there was going to be an issue
and the download was only
30 megabytes most of the main menu is
grayed out the only option you can click
takes you to a free play file where
money doesn't matter this is not a game
they keep changing what it's called
first it was called something tycoon
then university tycoon the developers
haven't even updated in like
almost a year i can't get a refund on
this crap ass game and steam won't do
about it
so do yourself a favor and don't buy
this game
not a game it is a piece of bs
wtf devs can you let us know what you
have done with our money
this is disgusting no replies no updates
this poor performance in my opinion
and finally awful
so the consensus is interesting because
people
think that there's potential in the idea
and yeah
university tycoon seems like it has
potential but let me tell you
that they are right this is
not a game and the gameplay that i did
record
will tell you the story of why this is
the newest
worst game on steam
okay this is university tycoon 2019
uh freeform games free
freeform games
what economy a work in progress yeah
you're telling me um
students none employees hire
no librarians no
uh schedules
um oh oh hey
hi hello
you all right um oh hi
hello careful okay
you're fine um uh okay
oh god no
wow uh
[Music]
can i rotate it yes i can
why does that also zoom in wait what
why does that why does rotating and zoom
in
whatever it's fine um yeah
okay okay
bam bam and bam
great um
hi you want to come to class in the
middle of the field are you coming
to study do you want to learn you're
more than welcome to
all right knowledge is power
okay it's sunday right now can i just
open everything all the time
and why only that early in the morning
wait someone's about to sit down
someone's coming to teach are you coming
to teach is it teaching time
why are you on that side of the
blackboard they're coming to learn
that's not how you sit at okay whatever
hang on i gotta finish all this uh can i
hire janitors i guess
well you're not on duty i don't know oh
boy oh boy okay education is open all
the time every time
why are they sitting on the park benches
and standing at the desks
you're right there lady oh
god no oh god
okay i have to figure out is there like
a tutorial no
this is the main menu the primary one
the
the main menu play okay
fat if i the camera
also go fast why would
camera also go fast building
oh wow wow
this is the worst way to rotate
ever do you hear my mouse
[Music]
why there we go here we go here we go
okay here we go i still don't know why
they're teaching
on that side i specifically put it over
there for this one it's probably because
i don't have a wall
but i don't know how to make a wall
because i don't know what literally any
of the buttons do
okay maybe if i just build it out of
doors
can i do that door door no it's not even
placing a door
maybe because i i don't have a wall air
conditioner here
be cool everyone cleaning kit stay clean
everyone
power knowledge is power everyone
double vending machine single vending
machine those don't line up
well the the school is booming i i think
uh
but i s how do you put down a goddamn
whoa guides anybody have a guide here no
no guides
screenshots no screenshots discussions
uh report for fraud when is it gonna
happen
not even one update don't do it
[Music]
okay they can't they're putting down
walls how okay they're in the
objects menu okay okay okay all right
they're doing something in the odd they
they got there from the object menu so
there's got to be something like
wall right construction uh
basic window no i can't even put these
down because i think they have to be
embedded
inside a wall cheap desk blackboard
basic wall basic wall
we're in business let's start up why is
it how did the window get placed
okay whatever let's start over we're
gonna go
out and we're gonna go back into
freeform games whatever that means
and we're gonna start from the beginning
uh object
area object oh i have no
men use okay all right maybe i got a
main menu nothing works okay um i'll tap
four
that works let's try it again
[Music]
objects okay we're good okay we got this
basic wall all right
let's make all right that works
we're gonna start off with a kind of a
box shape
yeah i'm gonna let my heart decide you
ever just let your heart
decide nailed it i am good on that okay
we're gonna have like uh hallways
defined like this
you know like this but we got an opening
no that we got a long hallway and then
an
open atrium you guys ever see an atrium
before you guys know atrium atrium
okay this will be the basic template for
a room
oh my god i hope there's a way delete
okay perfect
nope okay that's just there now you ever
look in the back of a school and you
just see a weird jutting out brick wall
all right basic door bam okay good door
i love the way it swings cleaning kit
you know what actually
this is good this is good because the
cleaning kit
will be tucked away back here all right
let's get some cheap
blackboards okay or not or it'll float
okay whatever does it just float up
oh my god i love the way it zooms out
okay it doesn't even glue to the wall i
know that they used the back of it
not the front of it so that's fine okay
all right the toilet
will be at the end of the hall so you
can really stare
we're gonna have a dueling toilet
at the end of all so people can really
stare each other down
that's great that's good that's great
okay
let's put a let's put a double door this
is like the
um well i i guess that's not quite right
but it's too late now i can't
ah let's make a wall of doors you know
it's gonna be like fall guys
some of them will be locked getting into
the classroom and if you don't go
through you'll be
you'll be tardy to class uh cheap desks
i'm zooming out apparently blah
okay blah blah blah blah blah
overcrowding in schools is a real
problem
especially here okay okay expensive desk
this is where
this is uh for the expensive class
still cramped but you know it is what it
is
okay we're almost there we're almost
here we're almost there bam bam bam and
bam
and then put some doors to get in
right here right here right here and
there there and then bang boom
we got ourselves a school let's get some
teachers one two three four
john doe one two three four janitors one
two three four
canteen one two three four librarians
one two three
four i didn't put a library in but i
didn't think that there was actually a
methodology for a library okay here they
come yeah yeah
yeah we got 20 people and well i mean
it's not like we have to worry about
business but you know it is what it is
um what do i
do now
what do i do now i build a school
what do i do
whoa okay can you not
get to those desks i don't know are you
teaching i don't know
go it's garbage
it's terrible it's not broken because
if you were to assume that it was broken
that would mean that you assume that
there's a fixed
state i'm going to leave now i want
nothing to do with this place or these
people
i want them to go on with their happy
little existences doing whatever it is
that they think they are doing
i'm actually going to leave my computer
running with these people here and i'm
assuming that over a million
years they will gain sentience and
realize the travesty of their own
existence
and then they will shut down the
computer from the inside
so there you have it uh i believe that
this game shouldn't even be on steam
they are charging people twenty dollars
i paid
20 for this game and i'm all for
supporting
developers making their dreams come true
this game
at 20 is like
putting money into a vending machine
that only kicks you in the balls and if
you don't have balls
it gives you balls and then kicks you in
the balls
you have to realize every single second
that you spend in that game
will never make up for the 20 that you
paid
for this game do not buy this one there
is no
hope it is only desolation and
destruction that waits
beyond the steam page of which this game
lurks
there is nothing for you to see here the
only thing of value is that it led to
this video
and even that is of questionable
material if this video was ever
worth your time thank you everybody so
much for watching
if you know of another game that could
possibly be worse than this
not just a broken game but just a bad
bad game let me know in the comments
below
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
bye